[Aplausos]
y horas por todo
no sabes llevar las cosas eres una
exagerada permites que todo te afecte
demasiado eres una drag mcqueen o suena
como muchos de vosotros yo he crecido
con esas frases y lo que es peor me las
he creído yo crecí pensando que mi
sensibilidad era algo malo algo que
tenía que esconder de lo que no debía
hablar así que eso es lo que hice y por
eso cuando aparecieron los primeros
síntomas de la ansiedad cuando
aparecieron incluso los primeros ataques
de pánico me lo calle porque claro yo
era una exagerada era una drama queen
tuve que hacer un máster en creación
literaria para que mi vida cambiará
en este máster una profesora nos encargó
un trabajo un poco extraño cuya premisa
era escribir un cuento en el que
contaremos algo que jamás le hubiéramos
contado a nadie y yo tenía clarísimo de
que quería hablar
esto es para mí la ansiedad
es un enredo de oscuridad es una espiral
que me atrapa que me deja sin aire sin
espacio sin luz y que lo convierte todo
en algo malo a veces la ansiedad se
queda conmigo durante días en mi cabeza
y me acompaña con náuseas vómitos
incapacidad para concentrarme la
sensación de que todo va a ir mal
incluso cuando todo va bien y a veces la
ansiedad explota y se convierte en un
ataque de pánico y entonces empieza lo
verdadero lo verdaderamente divertido la
sensación de despersonalización los
ahogos
la sensación de que estás perdiendo el
control de tu cuerpo y yo siento que mi
cabeza va tan rápido que voy a colapsar
de eso quería hablar yo de algo a lo que
en ese momento no le podía poner nombre
así que eso es lo que hice imagino que
si os digo que penséis en cómo trabaja
un escritor lo imaginaréis delante de un
escritorio delante de un ordenador y sí
tendréis razón pero a mí a veces me
gusta escribir narrando grabando me y
después pasándolo a limpio en el papel
adaptándolo esa es la técnica que
utilicé cogí mi grabadora
me puse delante del espejo tal y como
hacía la protagonista del relato y
empecé a narrar
tranquilamente muy lentamente y poco a
poco mientras hablaba me iba dando
cuenta de que las palabras del personaje
no eran suyas eran mías y de repente
estaba teniendo un ataque de pánico
doble el suyo y el mío y hoy en día
puedo acordarme de eso y decirlo riendo
o sonriendo al menos porque ahora sé que
sin eso no habría podido cambiar
permitirme ver un ataque de pánico desde
fuera me hizo ver
había algo ahí que eso tenía que tener
un nombre y yo necesitaba ese nombre
porque soy escritora y necesito la
palabra y sabía
que sin nombre la realidad no existe
como el color azul para la tribu de los
himba en namibia esta tribu es conocida
porque tiene una percepción del color
muy diferente a la nuestra no tienen una
palabra para determinar para definir el
color azul y eso según los estudios que
se han hecho hace que les cueste mucho
distinguirlo por ejemplo del verde pero
también que les cueste muchísimo
identificar el color azul cuando lo ven
de forma independiente
eso es lo que me pasó a mí con la
ansiedad que hasta que no le pude poner
un nombre hasta que no tuve una palabra
no pude identificar la primera en el
personaje y después en mí misma
a raíz de ese relato yo fui capaz de
hablar con mis padres de pedir ayuda de
empezar a ir a terapia y unos meses
después de desahogarme de la única forma
que se escribiendo una novela yo estaba
aterrorizada antes de publicar ese libro
porque creía que la gente iba a decir
que la protagonista era una drama cuento
erin la protagonista es un alter ego de
mí misma y la novela es una excusa para
hablar de cómo vive y cómo siente una
persona que convive día a día con la
ansiedad como os digo yo tenía miedo
pues la respuesta me dejó helada y llena
de tristeza porque no sabéis cuántas
personas se me acercaron y me dijeron la
ya
yo soy gerin te has metido en mi cabeza
como lo has hecho
e incluso muchas personas me decían que
gracias a este personaje han sido
capaces de darse cuenta de que lo que le
sucedía a ellos se llamaba ansiedad
yo eso no me lo esperaba
yo no escribí esta novela con la idea de
ayudar a nadie la escribí por egoísmo
por la necesidad de soltar todo lo que
llevaba dentro
lo escribí como forma de terapia y
resulta que ha sido la terapia de
algunas personas escribir ha convertido
mi ansiedad en un win win
y no me malinterpretéis porque yo estoy
muy contenta me siento muy feliz por
haber podido ayudar a alguien pero la
cuestión es que vivimos en la sociedad
de la información
cómo es posible que sepamos tan poco
sobre algo que afecta tantísimas
personas porque la ansiedad no es algo
minoritario en españa la ansiedad ya es
la primera enfermedad de causa no
directamente física por delante de la
depresión y ya se habla de la ansiedad
como la enfermedad silenciosa del siglo
y a pesar de eso
vivimos en la ignorancia porque porque
pese a lo que digan sigue siendo un tabú
es cierto que hoy en día decir que vas
al psicólogo están mucho más aceptado
que hace un tiempo pero hablamos de
trastornos mentales hablamos de lo que
sucede dentro de la consulta las
respuestas que no
y ese es el problema que vivimos en
silencio
es hora de romperlo si sufres ansiedad
y abre el espectro si sufres cualquier
tipo de trastorno de salud mental
habla con vuestros padres con vuestros
amigos escribir un libro o compone de
una canción haced hilos en twitter lo
que queráis pero no os quedéis en el
silencio porque el silencio fue lo que a
mí me hizo sentir durante tantos años
que como dice mi abuela estoy mal hecha
y a oscuras yo sentía que estaba rota
porque ni mi cabeza ni mi corazón iban
de la forma en que yo veía que
funcionaban las de mis compañeros y de
mis amigos yo me sentía demasiado
diferente
si entonces hubiera parecer un genio de
la lámpara yo le habría dicho que por
favor se llevara mi sensibilidad de una
vez que se llevara mi ansiedad pero
ahora sé que me habría equivocado porque
mi sensibilidad es lo que a mí me hace
ser quien soy y me hace ser la escritora
que soy sin mes y sin mi sensibilidad e
incluso sin mi ansiedad
yo no podría conectar como lo hago con
mis lectores
escribir me ha permitido ver eso que no
estoy rota que soy tan válida como
cualquier otra persona sienta como
sienta y sobre todo me ha hecho entender
que todas esas personas que durante
tantos años me han dicho que me callen
mis emociones estaban equivocadas porque
siempre siempre hay alguien cerca que
necesita escuchar que no está roto y que
no está solo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]